41 عاما من بداية الحرب عمري 15 عاما
أنهيت الصف الثامن وأذهب إلى الدورات
تدريب مشغلي الراديو في ستة أشهر أنا
يحث
متطوع وحدة عسكرية وأنا
إرسال جيش تشيليابينسك
مدرسة الطيران للملاحين والمدفعي
مشغلي الراديو أنا
بالفعل في الطاقم ، أيضًا ، قتال
[موسيقى]
سلمت الطائرة كانت متسابق بيري
هذه مهمة قتالية مسؤولة
لقد حصلت علينا لمدة 2 سنوات
[موسيقى]
القائد من حفظ الناس
ننظر بعناية في الشيك لكننا
نحن نعلم أنه قد يكون بانديرا بالفعل
قراشاي على رشاش مدفع باتجاه الغابة
الشريط بين
وكان هناك 12 شخصًا في هذا الجانب
ومن هنا رجل 10 15 سنة رشاش
تم الاجتياز بنجاح
لم يستلقي الجميع مرة أخرى وركضوا إلينا
وحدة لهزيمة النار
[موسيقى]
دفاعا عن جائزتين
الصغيرة تتحرك كثيرًا جدًا هناك
تأكل
تأمر الظلام بتكريم هذه الضربة لذلك
إنه من أجل الجدارة العسكرية
كما يقولون
ترغب في الاتصال مرة أخرى وإرسالها
تلقي رسائل من جيل الشباب
[موسيقى]